[Musique]
j'ai exactement
879 euros de revenus pour
880 euros de facture donc je suis depuis
le mois d'août je suis à zéro euro de
revenus pour me nourrir
bonjour ça va ça va
[Musique]
de tarte meringue
c'est un accueil c'est ce sont des
sourires une gentillesse de la part de
toutes ces personnes qui sont présentes
et qui apportent beaucoup en plus de
l'aide alimentaire on a une aide
psychologique
vanessa est à eux ETH accompagnant
d'élèves en situation de handicap depuis
4 mois maintenant elle bénéficie de
l'aide alimentaire au resto du coeur au
centre de Beaulieu elle a désormais ses
petites habitudes
prochaine
Vanessa accompagne une petite fille au
collège 25 heures par semaine un métier
passion qui ne lui permet pas de vivre
correctement
je pourrais changer de métier mais j'ai
pas envie j'ai pas envie j'aime mon
métier j'aime ce que je fais j'aime
apporter mon aide et mon écoute au
élèves et je trouve pas normal de devoir
être obligé de changer de métier pour
pouvoir vivre plus confortablement
pour réduire ses charges elle a fait le
choix de vivre en colocation et cet été
de pousser la porte des Restos du cœur
ça a été très compliqué
psychologiquement
il faut pouvoir accepter après
j'avoue qu'en ayant poussé la porte je
suis tombé sur des personnes
extraordinaires qui ont su m'accueillir
et me faire oublier justement ce
sentiment de de gêne et de ma lettre
les travailleurs pauvres
une nouvelle catégorie
socioprofessionnelle désormais
majoritaires au resto du coeur à
Beaulieu ils étaient plus de 40 pour la
campagne d'été sur les 64 personnes
accueillies mais d'autres visages encore
viennent demander de l'aide merci
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de retraités qui
arrivent nous voir
avec quelques étudiants mais c'est
surtout les retraités avec les hausses
des prix enfin les hausses de DF enfin
tout ce qui va avec quoi il n'y arrive
plus quoi
[Musique]
Saint-Benoît-du-Sault à 50 km au sud de
Châteauroux
bonjour
donc aujourd'hui on va charger
le camion Dominique Janis et Lionel
prépare le centre itinérance il est
opérationnel depuis un an
celui-là en premier
35 bénévoles assure ce service de
proximité auprès de bénéficiaires isolés
des zones blanches dépourvues
d'associations d'épicerie solidaire ou
de grandes surfaces
[Musique]
pendant la première campagne d'hiver
plus de 15000 repas ont été distribués
sur les quatre communes desservies sur
le sud du département
bonjour comment tu vas
et ben voilà
aux légumes après ils reviennent vous
trouver et puis on leur donne parce que
suivant ce qu'ils ont besoin parce
qu'ils ont droit exactement
il y a des points voilà si ça dépend
combien ils sont à la maison de ou 4
tout dépend il y a 36 points là
mais en milieu rural il est bien
difficile d'avouer que l'on va au resto
du coeur
c'est pas évident pour elle avec 600
euros de retraite
par la payer son loyer tout ça c'est pas
elle a pas grand chose à manger après
mal aux épaules
30 ans tout ça ça change pas la vie
d'imposition
là actuellement on est en train de faire
la réinscription des bénéficiaires qui
sont déjà inscrits pour la campagne
d'hiver qui va démarrer au mois de
novembre
cette année dans cette nouvelle campagne
on va prendre en charge tout ce qui est
électricité l'eau le chauffage même le
bois tout ça qu'on ne faisait pas les
autres années parce que ça devient de
plus en plus difficile donc là on va
accueillir plus de monde pour la
campagne d'hiver avec cette nouvelle
redistribution quoi
l'inflation va faire basculer davantage
de citoyens dans la précarité en une
semaine d'inscription 4 nouvelles
familles sur cette commune de 1300
habitants sont éligibles à l'aide
alimentaire
bonjour vous allez bien plus de
bénéficiaires mais déjà moins de denrées
alimentaires et des frais de
fonctionnement qui vont exploser
siège départemental à l'heure de
préparer la distribution du jour le
trésorier le président font le tour du
dépôt c'est la saison des pommes et les
pommes c'est pas fragile donc ça tombe
bien là on a quelques petits problèmes
je parle pas des légumes mais sur le riz
et les pâtes comme ailleurs on a les
mêmes problèmes que dans la vie normale
c'est-à-dire les pâtes les riz là on en
a plus
tout ce qui est féculents les œufs avec
la grippe aviaire on a aussi un petit
peu de problèmes
mais sinon
ça suit on fait on fait on se débrouille
si l'approvisionnement est tendue
d'autres lignes comptables sont à
surveiller de très près les dépenses
d'énergie on risque d'être impacter
terriblement au niveau des frais de
fonctionnement avec l'électricité encore
une fois le gaz et le carburant on
estime à peu près entre 6 et 8000 euros
sur un budget de 43000 vous voyez ce que
ça peut donner quoi c'est quand même
important quoi
alors le mot d'ordre pour cet hiver
c'est consommé moins le président fait
passer les consignes au bénévoles
attention quand vous partez assurez-vous
que les Lumières qui est pas un frigo
qui tourne avec rien dedans qui est pas
à des congels qui tournent avec oriental
pour faire les économies ça va être
difficile comme partout mais faut faire
comme à la maison
[Musique]
le petit gâteau au chocolat le thé et ça
va le faire
au centre de Beaulieu le petit café du
jeudi est un moment privilégié Dimitri
Rudy Laetitia et les autres parle de
tout de rien des galères des espoirs
bref de la vie
aujourd'hui la grande distribution sur
les produits alimentaires on va prendre
10%
vous avez une augmentation salariale qui
est entre deux et demi et 3%. donc
comment vous faites vous avez gaz
électricité qui est en train de péter
les scores donc comment vous faites donc
comme je vous dis aujourd'hui même la
personne qui travaille et qui gagne un
salaire vient au resto du coeur et c'est
alarmant c'est affolant plus
augmentation du gasoil aussi on en parle
même pas donc ouais ça devient très très
dur
comment on fait pour vivre avec 200 €
par mois
[Musique]
ou que oui les restos du cœur ont dû
s'adapter à de nouveaux publics et de
nouveaux besoins les centres désormais
sont devenus des lieux de vie j'ai un
petit problème ah oui oui
si on peut faire une petite clôture
on offre au bénéficiaire un service de
couture un coiffeur ou encore un
vestiaire pour s'habiller correctement
par exemple pour un entretien d'embauche
qui peuvent pas s'habiller puis on
essaie de leur apporter un peu
de plaisir aussi parce que c'est ça
quand il repartent avec des quelques
vêtements qui leur conviennent c'est ça
leur fait plaisir alors quand ils sont
contents quand ils sont heureux je suis
heureux
c'est l'une des dernières fois où
Dimitri remplit son caddie au resto du
coeur il a retrouvé un emploi et ne sera
bientôt plus éligible à l'aide
alimentaire
un CDI un logement à lui et même un
projet de voyage avec son fils pour lui
c'est bientôt la fin de la galère
moi maintenant je vais gagner mon
salaire
j'ai plus besoin de vous je vous
remercie enfin je vais bosser pour vous
et Catherine donc
tu viens jusque encore pendant deux
trois mois je comprends pas
quand on sort de la galère il y a
l'après galère
rembourser un peu les dettes voilà parce
que faut pas se leurrer et puis
recommencer une petite vie enfin je veux
dire moi j'ai pas de honte à dire j'ai
été au resto du coeur elle est où la
honte c'est justement je pense que on
sort on sort plus fort de cette
expérience
[Musique]
varia 420 salariés fleurons de
l'industrie agroalimentaire
ancien cuisinier Julien est aujourd'hui
pétrisseur et conducteur de four à la
fabrication des viennoiseries à Ris
bonjour Julien ravi de t'accueillir pour
ton premier jour CDI chez Barilla merci
c'est un grand jour pour ça aujourd'hui
très grand jour après un an et demi
d'intérim un premier CDI intérimaire
avec une agence Julien signe aujourd'hui
son CDI une sacrée revanche sur la vie
le contrat CDI
et une immense fierté pour se désormais
ancien bénéficiaire des Restos du coeur
exceptionnel plein de courage il
venaient sur son scooter avec par contre
une pluie
battante et d'ailleurs partait avec son
sac sur son dos et puis voilà et puis je
trouve que c'était un gamin formidable
une épine du pied qui est sortie
littéralement au niveau emploi j'ai plus
de j'ai plus de doute à me faire dessus
je sais que je peux faire ma carrière il
n'y a pas de souci
le travail de fond porte enfin ses
fruits pour le service du retour à
l'emploi c'est l'une des nouvelles
compétences des bénévoles des Restos
80% des personnes qui viennent me voir
jeunes ou moins jeunes d'ailleurs dans
la démarche retour de l'emploi on a un
résultat soit encore une fois sur des
formations longues rémunérées d'ailleurs
soit par le biais de l'intérim soit par
le biais de la Mission locale on a aussi
des sociétés qui nous contactent ce qui
était inimaginable il y a 3 ans
on ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'on puisse
avoir des pépites comme Julien dans
enfin parmi les personnes qu'on
accueille quoi c'est-à-dire il y avait
une connotation de se dire personne qui
va au resto du coeur personne un petit
peu en dehors de la société ou qui fait
pas ce qu'il faut pour se réinsérer
37 ans après sa création le visage de
l'institution de solidarité a bien
changé mais son créateur n'a pas à
rougir du service rendu qui a su
s'adapter à toutes les crises